nous sommes avec françois blanchecotte
président du syndicat des biologistes
bonsoir françois blanchecotte merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
est l'une des informations on en parlait
il ya quelques instants de la journée le
pass sanitaire qui qui finalement se
poursuivra jusqu'en novembre pour vous
c'est la bonne stratégie alors que
clairement l'épidémie marque le pas en
france
oui l'épidémie marque le pas mais en
même temps on va prendre une décision
aussi de plus rembourser les tests et
donc on va avoir moins de français qui
sont non vaccinés qui viendront dans nos
laboratoires donc il faut quand même
garder un oeil sur ce qui va se passer
au niveau de l'épidémie et donc de
continuer à faire le pas cet hiver s'est
d'emblée une sécurité et puis en fait la
politique du gouvernement pour
abandonner le remboursement des tests et
de favoriser ou d'orienter les français
pour la vaccination
donc on voit qu'on va dans le même sens
pour l'instant c'est plus une mesure de
prudence un ré effectivement c'est est
un bide de confort on se demande
toujours comment cet objectif a été
choisi pour ce genre de test pardonnez
moi ce trait d'humour mais effectivement
44 euros pour un pcr 22 euros pour un
test antigénique des scientifiques ont
critiqué aujourd'hui d'ailleurs cette
décision parlant même d' aberration
votre point de vue vous de biologistes
alors il est vrai qu'avec la gratuité
nous avions un système de surveillance
au jour le jour quasiment en photo
polaroïd instantanée nous savions tous
les jours le nombre de positif comment
évoluer sur les territoires la
circulation du virus on va être avec
cette mesure un peu plus aveugle c'est
certain on va certainement avoir des
éléments qui vont nous échapper alors
dans le même temps on va essayer aussi
de contrôler les écoles les primaires
l'école de façon à savoir un petit peu
comment le virgule le virus à circuler
quand on va arrêter le port du masque
donc on voit qu'il ya quand même des
mesures
barrière pour essayer de voir un petit
peu comment on peut juguler avoir une
idée de ce qui se passe pour vous cela
va marquer justement une hausse de
l'épidémie le fait de plus testé tout le
monde ou au contraire peut-être une
baisse qui n'en est pas une parce qu'on
n'aura pas les chiffres
ça peut toutes les hypothèses on sait
pas vraiment d'abord combien on veut
faire de tests on sait pas ce qui va se
passer à partir du 15 pour l'instant
nous avions continué à descendre mais
toujours avec un nombre très élevé
puisque la dernière semaine nous avions
2,1 millions de tests avec toujours un
peu de du million de pc r par semaine
donc on voit que les pcr ne baissez pas
forcément c'est plutôt les tests
antigénique qu'icbc maintenant on va se
rendre compte voir si les gens viennent
quand même se faire dépister je rappelle
quand même pour tous les français que
quand on a des symptômes même si on
n'est pas vacciné qu'on ait une
ordonnance on est quand même pris en
charge donc normalement les gens qui ont
des symptômes de qui pourrait penser à
l'aco vide ils ont quand même une prise
en charge alors clairement cette
nouvelle mesure on vous l'avait dit un
le gouvernement espère inciter et
augmenter la couverture vaccinale
c'est la vaccination à marche forcée
pour vous plutôt une bonne chose
finalement
écoutez moi je fais partie des gens et
des professions de santé qui sont
matinée très tôt cette année à partir de
début janvier on était convaincus quand
même que c'était un peu le seul moyen de
se sortir de cette torpeur que nous
avions et des mesures barrières qui
était contraignant on le voit
aujourd'hui que les français supporte de
moins en moins quand même le mars qu'ils
auront envie de retrouver un espace de
liberté et c'est vrai que cette
vaccination nous donne cette opportunité
maintenant je pense qu aura toujours une
frange de français qui se seront
irréductibles par contre on peut encore
convaincre à mon avis un certain nombre
de français surtout à l'aube de l'hiver
de ce refroidissement de la venue du
vinyle du virus grippal donc je pense
qu'il ya il ya quand même une
possibilité que ça se fasse
le gouvernement aujourd'hui un qui
autorise ce n'est pas obligatoire mais
qui autorise cette fameuse troisième
dose pour les personnels soignants dont
vous faites partie commence est
accueilli dans le monde et des soignants
parce qu'on sait que là aussi il ya eu
quelques récalcitrants
enfin la troisième dose est ce qu'elle
est aussi bien accueillie et les deux
premières quand même écouter ça commence
seulement on a vu la décision européenne
qui a validé un petit peu ce schéma on a
vu la décision française qui l'a qu'il a
entériné pour l'instant pour une partie
de la population que sont les soignants
il ya encore évidemment des résistances
à ici ou là ne soyons qu'ils veulent pas
se faire vacciner je pense que en tout
cas nous nous sommes convaincus que si
les nécessités de voir ce rappel si on a
des taux effectivement qu'ils peuvent
descendre au niveau de la protection
qu'elle est justifiée et qu'elle a qu'à
vraiment besoin de la voir avant
l'arrivée de l'hiver pour revenir sur
les tests un payant ce sera ma dernière
question il ya peut-être aussi quelques
contraintes budgétaires dans cette
décision ça rapidement
vous l'avez compris bien sûr le père fss
2021 et un peu explosé les tests ont été
extrêmement important et en très grand
nombre à partir de l'annnonce du pass à
lithaire obligatoires on a vu qu'on a
passé largement la fourchette des 4 5
millions de tests par semaine avec
souvent une grande partie de tests
antigénique et donc c'est ce correctif
qui arrive on retrouve un peu une
situation qu'on a connu en juin 2020
avant que les tests soient gratuits donc
on repasse sur un circuit vraiment de
symptômes 2 cas contacts on retrouve en
fait la philosophie que nous avions
avant et je pense que pour la plupart
des régions c'est nécessaire c'est
suffisant par contre il faut être
vraiment attentif si ça redémarre s'il
ya des clusters qui débute il faut
absolument qu'on les explore et qu'on
ait identifié toutes les personnes qui
pourraient être positives merci beaucoup
françois la banque était avec nous en
direct sur arte france